the Malaysian King has named Anwar
Ibrahim as the country's new prime
minister the announcement ends days of
uncertainty after last week's election
gave no clear majority to any political
party let's go to Florence Louis who is
in Kuala Lumpur Florence what exactly
has been announced
while the King has another Palace rather
has announced that Anwar Ibrahim will be
sworn in as the country's 10th prime
minister at 5 PM local time on Thursday
now this ends the sort of political
impasse this country has experienced
since Saturday's elections returned an
inconclusive winner and for Anwar as
well this is the culmination of a
journey of decades he was first a an
Heir Apparent to the position of prime
minister he was a deputy prime minister
at one point and then he was jailed for
sodomy and Corruption on charges that a
lot of his supporters say are
politically motivated and indeed widely
seen as politically motivated since his
release he's been the leader of
opposition he's built up this whole
opposition movement known for its cause
of government reform he's let the
opposition Coalition which was made up
of disparate groups with very different
ideals and policies coming together to
really increase in strength from
election to election now he was very
nearly made the Prime Minister when the
opposition Coalition won a historic
election in 2018 but the opposition
Coalition which was then in government
fell apart because of infighting and
defections and his chances of being
prime minister had evaporated and this
time his Coalition or the alliance of
hope they won the largest number of
seats in Parliament but still not enough
to form a majority and that's why there
was this whole horse trading that took
place over five days because the two
largest winners of the election could
not form coalitions and so the
Constitutional Monarch had to step in
and appoint as he's constitutionally
empowered the person he thinks is able
to command the confidence of the
majority now there's still no answer
about the shape of this government
whether it's going to be a Unity
government made up of members of
parliament who will be appointed to
ministerial positions from the second
largest block which is also the Rival
for um anwas Alliance of hope and in
fact the leader of the second largest
block muyin Yasin had initially said
that he will not be working with the
alliance of hope so it is kind of I mean
so the country has a prime minister now
but it is still difficult to see whether
or not this will be a stable government
thank you for that Florence Louis in
Kuala Lumpur